hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
at a number of points in his work all
things are possible
lev chesterf is going to discuss what
what he views
as the relationship between philosophy
and what he's calling logic which is
covering a lot of grounds he'll also
talk about
logical argumentation he'll talk about
the habit of logical thinking he'll also
talk about
dialectics and we also have to be
careful philosophy's relation with logic
is not something
simple and straightforward in part
because
philosophy itself is not something
that you can just you know give a
definition of and now fully understand i
mean that would be a very logical
approach to it
but that would be part of the problem
and it's complicated a little bit
further because philosophy
oftentimes is missing its mark
according to shestop so he's engaging in
philosophy
he's pointing out some models of how to
do philosophy well
he's also explaining where philosophy
became
over-reliant on what he calls logic or
this this broad sense which includes as
i said dialectics and
logical argumentation and so we we have
to you know sort of piece together
a composite picture i think a good place
to start
is in part two chapter nine where he
talks about
a point of view and here he's not just
talking about philosophers he says
every writer thinker even every educated
person thinks that necessary to have a
permanent point of view
he climbs up some elevation never climbs
down again all his days
whatever he sees from this point of view
he believes to be reality truth justice
good
and what he does not see he excludes
from
existence and so he's he's actually
being a little bit hyperbolic there not
every thinker is doing this obviously
there's some thinkers
who are much more flexible including
himself right
but this is a tendency and what does it
lead to
he goes on and he says we have no wings
and a winged thought is only a nice
metaphor
unless of course it refers to
logical thinking so this notion of the
efficacy of logical thinking is already
based on something
like a metaphor and he says he who
really wishes to know something and not
merely to have a philosophy
a philosophy in the sense of having like
some sort of orientation
some sort of system so somebody who's
not just doing that
does not rely on logic and is not alert
by
reason he must clamber from summit to
summit and if necessary hibernate
in the dales so he says um
you have to be willing to engage in a
certain kind of
empiricism you might call it and an
empiricism that goes beyond that of the
empiricists who themselves are
all too rationalist and and uh all too
you know devoted to logic so something
that would be
like what william james calls a radical
empiricism right
so this is a good starting point another
one i think
is his we could call it a denigration of
logic he's
it's also a caution as well and he's
talking about again what goes into
good thinking and good writing and he
tells us this is in
book part 1 chapter 14 what is the task
of
of a writer to go forward and share his
impressions with his
reader he's not obliged to prove
everything
again the experiential the empirical
side of things you might also say a
certain sort of partiality
and particularity as well so
here he actually calls logic along with
morality and science those police agents
right
and what do we mean by that well at the
time that that chest off is writing
particularly as a russian writer the
police agents are the ones who
are not just you know the cop on the
corner they're the ones carrying out
investigations and throwing people into
jails
and interrogating them and making sure
that that things stay
nice and calm and that things go on as
usual so
morality science logic he says and so
the writer needs to have some
sort of argument with which to frustrate
them
so you can't just say i don't believe in
you at all
instead you have to have some sort of
some sort of thing to give them
and here he says something that might
appear rather cynical i think i find a
comical instead
he says there's no necessity to trouble
too deeply about the quality
of the argumentation why fret about
being inwardly right
it's quite enough if the reasoning which
comes handiest will succeed in occupying
those guardians of the verbal highways
whose intention it is to obstruct his
passage
so part of our engaging in in writing in
general or
expressing ourselves in a coherent way
which could include philosophy
is like throwing bones to logic and
science and morality
so they can occupy themselves with that
and then we can get on with the real
business over here
undisturbed and maybe even a real
dialogue or conversation
so this is a great lead-in to
his discussions that arise at two points
about what we might call being logical
about
logic and he asks you know
should we just discard logic this is in
part one uh chapter 106
and he says no that would be extravagant
why would we
simply discard logic that would be
rather
excessive he says why should we for the
sake of consequentialism
he doesn't mean consequentialism the way
we typically talk about it today is a
set of moral theories
he means being consequential being
logical if we're going to like discard
logic are we doing it for the sake of
being
logical and he says uh for the for
logic's own self and he says
but logic as an aim in itself or as even
the only means to knowledge is a
different matter against this
one must fight even if he has against
him all the authorities have thought
beginning with
aristotle so if logic is going to be
viewed as something that's just you know
a tool
you know you could say value neutral
doesn't come with any sort of
implications or obligations of its own
uh we can take it or leave it and that's
fine if
people are going to you know belong to
what we could call today
the you know logic reason science camp
the people are like
bashing you with that and you know
recently
blowing up the correspondence theory of
truth which rightly understood doesn't
cover everything right
into something like an ideology well
then you should push them away say no no
no we're not going to go for that
that would make sense so we have to make
a distinction within
how we're using logic uh about its its
aims
um he also talks about skepticism and
this is in uh
chapter 44 of part one and he says a
school
axiom logical skepticism refutes itself
since the denial of the possibility of
positive knowledge
is already an affirmation and we're all
familiar with these sorts of
you know textbook dismissals right if
you're going to assert that you know
we can't know anything well you're
already asserting that we know that if
you're gonna assert there is no truth
is that true itself right it's almost
like that meme
with the the guy who's like oh you use
this
you can't possibly criticize it isn't
that interesting right
it's the same sort of logic behind that
and chest off says this doesn't actually
convince anybody you can do what you
want because logic doesn't have
the sway that we want to say he says in
the first place skepticism is not bound
to be logical it has no desire to
gratify that dogma
which raises logic to the level of
law if logic is going to have some
validity it's going to be based on
something other than logic and so we're
going to have to investigate well what
is that
maybe it's going to vary from place to
place it could just be
usefulness it could be you know sort of
a pragmatic motif for for logic
which the logicians are not going to
like and it could be
just you know we desire to have things
be that way
so you know the rationality of logic is
based on a kind of irrationality or
non-rationality of desire so we should
ask the question then why
logic chest off gives us
several different interesting
explanations which don't have to be
blown up into like
the single theory of where logic came
from in a genetic sense
one is he talks about you know socrates
and plato and there's sort of just
stand-ins
for other philosophers in this case we
can think about people
down to the present who are like this we
can even think of non-philosophers
who are like this as well and he says
that
socrates and plato tried to determine
under the shifting change of appearance
the immutable unchanging reality
the platonic forms are an example of
this and he said here's what their their
basic concept was
the um that which is real must be
constant
hence the ideas of objects are real and
the objects themselves are
fictitious and he says the root of
platonic philosophy appears to be a
fundamental defect
in human reasoning a defect regarded as
the highest
merit and what is it he says it's
difficult for a philosopher to get a
good grasp of this agitated capricious
life
and so he decides that's not life at all
but a figment
dialectics is supreme over only general
concepts and the general concepts are
promoted
to an ideal and since socrates and plato
with
a lot of variations philosophers been
saying well
you know whatever is general whatever is
universal whatever is unchanging that's
what's most real
and all this other stuff that we're
experiencing and our own existential
position in in this weird thing we call
life ah that that's just particularity's
not really that important
so that's that's one thing that gives
rise to
what he's calling here dialectics
dialectics works great with general
concepts
not quite so good at the real
in our sense stuff that we're we're
dealing with
he also talks about logic as providing a
common ground for the activity of
argumentation
this is in chapter 45 part one
it says the aristotelian logic which
forms the chief component in modern
logic arose
as we know as a result of the permanent
controversies
which were such sport to the greeks in
order to argue
we have to have common ground in other
words to agree about the rules of the
game
and then he goes on and he says in our
day dialectical tournaments
like other bouts of contention are no
longer attracting people so logic can be
relegated to the background
and there's there's really two things to
point out about this passage so somebody
might quibble and say wait a second
aristotelian logic
very different than modern predicate
logic and sure
that's true you know although you know
you could find antecedents in the stoic
logic as well if you want to and
the main point here is not about the
particularities of the logical
operations that you're working with
the main point here is about the
systematization
of what are going to count as rules for
engaging in argumentation with each
other and there you can say yeah the
aristotelian logic
is basically carried forward into most
modern logic i mean there's a few
exceptions here and there
so that's one important point the other
important point is is chest off actually
right
in saying ah people really aren't that
interested in this sort of stuff
i mean think about the uh craziness
involved in these debates happening in
social media
between people who are all worked up
about you know how how important logic
is
and you know it's extension to science
mathematics all those sorts of stuff now
people are really
debating these matters um that's why
people can be so upset about what they
take to be postmodernism
or if it was you know 20 years earlier
relativism
or any any of these sorts of things
he's got a much more you could say
metaphysically and and uh history of
philosophy oriented
discussion in uh chapter 121
towards the end of part one you talk he
starts out saying a equals a
right law of identity they say logic
doesn't need this postulate and i could
easily develop it by deduction i think
not
on the contrary in my opinion logic
could not exist without this premise
and then he says and let me blow your
mind a little bit more
it has a purely empirical origin in the
realm of fact
a is always more or less equal to a but
it could be otherwise
so what is going on when we're insisting
on a thing is a thing
it can't be something different than
itself right we're the ones insisting on
that
we're the ones who are maybe even
contrary to experience saying
this this has to be this way and and
we're turning logic into
a police agent that way he says
the universe might be so constituted as
to admit of the most fantastic
metamorphoses that which now equals a
would successively equal b
and then c and so on at present a stone
remains
long enough a stone a plant to plant an
animal an animal
but it might be that a stone changed
into a plant before our eyes and planted
to an animal
there is nothing unthinkable in such a
supposition
and that's proved by the theory he says
of evolution
it puts centuries in place of seconds
now that's not a really great
argument there but he says anything
you please may come from anything you
please a may not equal a
and consequently logic is dependent
for its soundness on the empirically
derived law
of the unchangeableness of the external
world
you know and so there's a couple things
going on here there's kind of a human
you know if we can think it otherwise
it's not absolutely necessary and that's
that's a point that runs throughout all
of chestop's works
logic requires a kind of necessity it
talks about itself as being the laws of
thought
he also brings in another thing admit
the possibility of supernatural
interference and logic will lose that
certitude and inevitability of its
conclusions which at present is so
attractive to us
so he's not actually saying god exists
therefore
you know logic is is not as reliable as
we think he's saying
the mere possibility of supernatural
intervention which you could rule out at
the start if you want to
but that would be illogical to do that
because you don't have any evidence for
ruling it out
right other than the fact that you want
logic to work this way
it makes things uh more dependent
what are the problems with relying on
logic over much in philosophy he notes a
number of them
one is that it leads to a kind of
armchair philosophy he talks about this
in uh chapter 13 of part two
and he's actually using that word
armchair philosophy talking about
philosophy
within your room where you never
actually get outside and see anything
else and
everything is perfectly logically
consistent because you never
let anything that would disrupt stuff in
there and therefore it becomes rather
sterile and has
nothing to do with life he also talks
about the habit
now notice he doesn't say logical
thinking by itself kills imagination
he says that instead this is a
chapter 21 of uh part one
he says that the habit of logical
thinking
kills imagination what does he mean by
the habit of logical thinking
you're always relying on logic he says
man is convinced that the only way to
truth is through logic and any departure
from this way leads to error and
absurdity
now there's a lot of things in which we
probably should use logic right again he
said
don't throw logic completely away that
would be extravagant why would you do
that that would be illogical
right and illogical or irrational in a
broad sense
but to rely too much on logic all the
time to say well if it can't be treated
by logic
it must not exist or it must not be
important or it's just sheer rationality
well we leave out a lot of stuff we
leave out the things that matter to us
or should matter to us most he says the
nearer we approach the ultimate
questions of existence
in our departure from logicality the
more deadly becomes the
state of error we fall into and this is
him portraying the logician
saying and he's got this metaphor of the
ariadne ball right
ariadne was the daughter of minos who
gave
a ball of twine or thread or yarn
to theseus when he had to go into the
minotaur's house
the uh the maze right the labyrinth
and he was able to find his way back out
because of that after he
kills the minotaur so um
he goes on and says the ariadne ball has
become unwound long ago
and we're at the end of the tether we
don't know we hold the we
hold the end of the thread firmly and we
mark time with energy on the same spot
imagining progress
we don't even realize that we ran out of
thread
a while back and that we might have
pulled it along and we might not be able
to find our way
home so he says um
he would have been better to stay at
home once he set out once he decided to
be a thesis and kill the minotaur
he should have given himself up
forfeited the old attachment and been
ready to never to escape
from the labyrinth and over relying on
logic kills our other capacities that
would allow us to move forward if we're
always staying
in our nice safe place we're not going
to move
another big problem logic you know it's
useful but there can be some pretty
arbitrary conclusions because we often
don't know enough
to make it entirely effective he has
this great example this is in chapter
104
of giving somebody bread he says
a hungry man's given a piece of bread
and a kind word the kindness seemed more
to him than the bread
but had he been given only the kind word
and no bread he probably would have
hated nice phrases caution
is to always be recommended in the
drawing of conclusions
right the connections of isolated
phenomena can very rarely be discerned
as a rule several causes at once produce
one effect
owing to our propensity for idealizing
we always make prominent that cause
which seems to us loftiest so the
abstraction that logic
likes to to have us engage in can lead
us to misunderstanding what's going on
and drawing the wrong conclusions
he also talks about some great thinkers
who are basically
indifferent to he says logic and
common sense and um you know what does
this
actually show us well we'll read a
little bit of this because he's got some
some some really
great uh discussions here
he says that uh here we go
modern instances are nietzsche and
schopenhauer both present noble examples
of indifference to logic and common
sense
particularly schopenhauer who a
conscience
even in the name of kant made such
daring sally's against reason driving
her
into confusion and and shame right and
so
he he goes on and he says that um
uh here we go we've got we've got
schopenhauer
we've got nietzsche um and he says that
uh
philosophy there is indeed much more
music than logic and the philosophy of
schopenhauer
not for nothing is he excluded from the
universities but
we can speak of him in the open not of
his ideas naturally but of his
his music the european market is glutted
with ideas
how neat and nicely finished and
logically well turned out those ideas
are schopenhauer had no such goods
but what lively and splendid
contradictions he boldly spreads on his
stall
often even without suspicion you want to
hide them from the police the police are
of course
logic right and so what can we draw as a
conclusion from this
listen there's multiple ways of doing
philosophy and if you want to do
philosophy in a very strict logical way
okay but you know even if you do
somebody like schopenhauer may come
along and turn that on its head or
somebody like nietzsche
may come along or or other thinkers as
as well
the last thing i'll point out is he says
a deep conviction
is more powerful than logical
argumentation this is in chapter
27 of part two and he's he's often right
about this
you know we we count on logic as if it's
going to be
producing its own self evidence and its
own
ground and and chest off is saying no it
can't do that
at best it can be something that's
useful from time to time for us in
philosophy
but over reliance on logic as being at
the core of philosophers being
you know the thing that decides for all
of us is actually going to keep us from
philosophizing well
that is in any way that engages with our
existential condition and the lives that
we're
leading
you